carl um it was a big weekend uh there's
crime
there's weather but the border crisis it
continues and it seems to be picking up
speed
oh absolutely and i think former
congressman gowdy is absolutely on
target we cannot
get this issue resolved until we make
until we decide to get it resolved and
border security is critical
i do think he's right i think there's
some people out there who are very happy
to have this remain as a political issue
people on both sides frankly but uh
you know this this is this is a terrible
problem for our country
and we better get control of it you know
i'm amazed the biden administration is
talking about getting rid
of the of the trump administration rule
that said for public health reasons
we're going to immediately turn back
into mexico uh
people that we get from people who are
trying to cross the border
and and i don't understand why we're
trying to do that why we're trying to
reverse this
is the health crisis gone do we have no
problems anymore from covid
you know what i saw the administration
the buy administration think about doing
this
i wouldn't check the vaccination rates
46
of all americans are vaccinated in
mexico
it's 16 about a third of what it is in
the united states
but think about the countries from which
we're seeing these flows come guatemala
less than one percent are vaccinated
honduras
almost a half a percent same in el
salvador nicaragua doesn't even report
how many people
are vaccinated at so little and what
does that mean that means that we have
people who
are more likely to have coven who are
coming into the united states who have a
much higher prospect of having covet and
and we're going to let we're going to
release them in a vulnerable part of our
country where the health systems
are are already strained and can be
easily overwhelmed by
people who are sick and need to be taken
care of the contradiction is stunning
you're talking about title 42 right carl
the report suggest that by the end of
july they would reverse that decision
which would mean that the folks coming
across from mexico would no longer be
turned away
and the reason why title 42 was put in
there is because they were trying to
make sure
you don't bring a lot of covet into the
country i mean it's really backwards
yeah now remember earlier in this year
we literally had to have these
communities along the border
uh had to pay for their own testing
because people were coming across the
border being released
and wandering through their downtowns
and get to the bus station
and they literally the bus company said
before we allow anybody on our bus
they need to be tested because people
are getting sick
our staff are getting sick other
passengers are getting sick we've got to
have a policy that nobody gets on that
bus
unless they've been tested and of course
that put even greater pressure inside
places like brownsville and harlingen
and
mcallen uh star county where where roma
is is one of the poorest
counties in america and and and think
about
if you release all those people what
kind of demands that are going to be
placed immediately on the social
services of that county
they need to be fed they need to have
transportation they need to have
uh health care and and that community is
already
strained to the limits already with its
own normal problems
without adding this on top of it karl
roves keeping an eye on everything for
us
in the state sending law enforcement to
the arizona and texas border to help
florida idaho nebraska you can imagine
there's probably going to be more to
come on that
thank you carl nice to see you i went on
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now